Speaker 1: Let's go next to oh, I don't know,
why don't we go to Frank from Jersey Frank,
you're on the air.
Hello, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Hey, how are you doing today?
Speaker 1: Good.
And please, please, please turn off Discord
notifications because we're every time that
brings, it's coming through.
Speaker 3: I'm sorry, I have the I have do
not disturb on, so I'm not sure why.
Is there something else that I should have
said?
Speaker 1: Yeah, in your settings notifications,
just turn all of those damn notifications
off settings notifications, and then we'll
stop hearing that and it'll be beautiful.
OK.
How's that?
All right, let's see what was on your mind
today, I don't know if it worked, but let's
see.
No, it did not work.
Give me your question and we'll take the answer
offline.
Speaker 3: OK, I'm sorry.
So basically, I'll just start with the first
one.
Right now, I'm having a little bit of a family
issue where my parents were originally very,
you know, logical with their decisions regarding
COVID and being safe and, you know, actually
wearing their mask and everything.
But now, unfortunately, it's kind of gotten
to a point where, I mean, you know, he even
showed up yesterday with like a cloth mask,
and it was just something from like the doctor's
office with like an insurance name on it.
And you know, this is somebody who does understand
N95 and things like that.
They're not vaccinated.
They just keep kind of getting more and more
crazy conspiracies off the internet.
And I'm kind of finding it hard to, you know,
even using some of your advice in earlier
streams that I've watched of yours to combat
conspiracy theorists finding it really, really
hard to talk to them with a lot of the kind
of like you keep putting it lately, very,
very weaponized information.
Speaker 1: What's the conspiracy theory?
Well, give me give me what's a conspiracy
theory that they believe right now?
Speaker 3: I mean, I'm almost embarrassed
to say them, to be honest, but like just give
an idea is like recently New Year's, I really
wanted to see them.
And instead he was telling me that because
me and the woman I live with is vaccinated,
the vaccine is going to spread to COVID to
them, and we're the ones that is actually
going to cause it through the spike proteins.
And like eight thousand other, you know?
Yeah, that's that's it.
Speaker 1: That's one of the craziest ones.
That's like the woman who said she was experiencing
rectal bleeding when she went near vaccinated
people.
I mean, that I don't that's that's a pretty
deep hole you got to dig your way out of.
You know, I don't know.
And if and you're saying that the casual Socratic
method of questioning doesn't work with them,
Speaker 3: I have tried almost every logical
type of like, you know, reasoning, even even,
for example, they're slightly religious.
I'm not into it, but you know, they for some
reason believe that this is something that
is like an opinion thing and not fact or science
based.
Yeah.
And that's what I think is I can't crack this
wall.
And unfortunately, my mother just goes based
off of whatever my father finds, and he's
just stuck on the internet for eight or 10
hours a day on, you know, rumble and bitch
shoot and all this other garbage.
Speaker 1: Oh my god.
So listen, it sounds like you've tried a lot
of things, I think as a last ditch effort
before considering, you know to what degree
you want to continue engaging in this stuff
would be try to go with a very common sort
of psychoanalytic question, which is what
would it mean for you if this belief weren't
true if you were wrong about this?
Because sometimes if you can't pierce with
the Socratic questions like how did you come
to believe this?
Sometimes people have a lot of emotion in
psychology and meaning tied up in their beliefs.
And it's a last ditch.
I don't know that it's going to do too much,
but but I might say, Well, what would it mean
to you if it weren't true that walking around
in your vaccinated people did any of this
stuff and the vaccines actually work?
Like, what would that mean to you?
And see what happens?
That's my only other idea.
Speaker 3: That's actually a really interesting
perspective, I appreciate that because I know
it's a hard kind of thing to just throw at
you, but listen, I know I already took up
a lot of time.
I really appreciate all the work that you
do and you know, you really put out a great
article every every day.
So thank you.
Very.
Speaker 1: All right.
Thanks, Frank from Jersey and learn from Frank
guys.
Turn off all notifications, all notifications,
and try not to use speaker.
We can do this, folks.
I know we can do this, but we've got to all
work together.
All right, let's go.
We have two callers named Tristan.
We have Tristan in Boston and Tristan in Kansas.
Let's maybe start first with Tristan in Boston.
You were on the air.
Christine, in Boston, you were on the air.
Terrorists than in Boston, last call for Tristin
in Boston.
No such luck there